oi e aí galera que assiste meu canal
tudo bom com vocês ou não é isso meu
deus meu deus meu deus que loucura mais
vídeo e um mês que deve estar
acontecendo só pode ser uma pandemia
volume de vídeos aumentou agora porque
eu estou isolado na quarentena de 20
dias estamos fechado em casa como se
fosse um big brother só que quem assiste
é só nós aqui graça e conhece né aí cara
tô aqui né de blusa o teu estado de
emergência quando eu tiver de luva é
porque o negócio é feio ninguém tem
informação suficiente as informações
atravessada um negócio estranho que
ninguém sabe tem gente que a tá na maior
cuidado tem gente que sai de casa no
vídeo normalmente usa máscara não usa
máscara não a máscara é só para quem tá
com sintoma e já deve ter um monte de
gente precisa do teu tempo que eu
comprei a máscara no dia de mandar botar
papéis tocou das informação atravessado
e eles estão psicológico das pessoas por
que dentro de cada um si mesmo si
próprio a peça ou quer dizer que não
precisa usar máscara quando você ver uma
pessoa com as roupa de astronauta para
mim por
o bom é essas pessoas aqui ó elas estão
protegidas que de astronauta em tu ainda
tem que ficar se abalar a daqui uns dia
de mundo né ela tem que botar a massa
little [ __ ] eu tinha uma dessas o cara
foi minha vida que foi daí pisou na
minha está olha o vírus aqui para de
lutar ai coloca vai daqui cachorro o
coronavírus que está mantida a
residência maravilha mais informando
direito mesmo parece que disseram agora
a última vez que disser dizendo assim
agora essa valeu máscara é só para
pessoas com sintomas ok limpar mão é
para todo mundo hein olha o whindersson
educação olha o único e também pode
tirar os anéis se quiser você pensava
que eu ia cometer este erro amador logo
aqui no meu ensino não é não mesmo amigo
não mesmo só
tô pensando sintoma como é que você
identifique os sintomas porque o
espírito parece que também é um sintoma
só que eu espirro o a tim é o mais comum
a tim ele é como mas não quer dizer que
é o único espirro tem gente que inspira
estranho demais meu amigo este diabo
desta corolla eu percebi tegiacchi e
estranho a gente fez assim ó para se
abrir uma lata de refrigerante que deve
ter um filhote de gato
[Música]
e tem gente espinha para dentro parece
que sai só suspiros
é o da minha vó para ficar no espirrar
claro que ela explodir nas mãos se não
tiver pode ser tão eficiente quanto está
acabando né como pode um pânico porque
não tem mais álcool gel acabou é o
apocalipse gente dá para lavar as mãos é
tão lindo quanto você que tem água tem
que ter uma porcentagem de áudio eu te
aviso tudo isso aquela prevenção do
coronavírus era você não levar suas mãos
à boca aos nariz os olhos e os vampiros
só que coisa tava lendo a notícia tava
assim alho e aí ó
o que foi não me chama tem o velho
método logo gel gente não tem mais cor
ou nós não tem mais a sério mesmo é vida
muito tá coçando os olhos bota na mão na
boca e tudo mais tanto falar estão
menino vai lá que a mão na merda do
cachorro aí bota a mão na boca e veio
acompanhando aí o pai quem foi o menino
e o y está ali na televisão um grande o
desgraçado desse vírus cara desse
coronavírus ele sobrevive nove dias em
cima da superfície 9 dias tá aqui nesse
mouse 9 dias ele fica aqui ó que eu
estou encostou coronavírus aqui o nome
dias em cima da superfície 9 dias esse
desgraçado é no desgraçado um negócio
que não que não morre nove dias em cima
do meu nove dia aqui nove dias com
serginho morro aqui tem condição
confortável por não tem encosto né para
ver se a pessoa não tem como sobreviver
ninguém passa aqui e me pega entendi é
aí uma metáfora vontade [ __ ] que pariu
aqui ó eu parei para olhar de novo as
informações do coronel que eu tinha
notado assis
a falar besteira é que parece que é a
maior [ __ ] isso aqui mas eu também
dou uma olhadinha para não falar merda
aqui também aí eu tinha anotado os casos
que tinha ontem tinha 300 e tantos casos
confirmados hoje tem 621 caso confirmado
na hora que eu tô gravando esse vídeo
olha o tanto que se espalhou decreto de
calamidade pública primeiros testes e
vacinas e humanos olha aí eu já li aqui
uma notícia legal bacana piauí por
enquanto três casos foram identificados
como coronavírus que alguém está com
zero casos que o colono não chega lá né
ele ele já beirando a fronteira o sol
mata mas foram feito alguns exames né
que demora muito para sair agora
apareceu três casos positivos mas fé em
deus vai ficar só nisso mesmo porque a
gente tem poucos exames para fazer então
se não tem exame não tem corona não vai
dar uma alteraçãozinha ali na taxa de
mortalidade da gripe normal ali não sei
porque eu sei é esse ano aumentou aqui
mas o piauiense ele pega pouco eu cuscuz
e corta né coronavírus não resisti
o floco de milho quando ele é grande ele
partículas se tornando a gente mais uma
lógico né eu sou muito numa lógica então
eu sou imune ao coronel que eu soltar
esse negócio é lógico na minha vida
nessa não tem uma lógico que ele família
de roma longe do sansão hematológicas
então eu sendo muito imunológico isso aí
para mim é o de mínimo muita coisa tá
parando para nós comer ar né por exemplo
ali quando você vai de teresina para
fortaleza que você passa aquela estrada
que é cheia de buraco ali eu não entendi
porque ainda tô usando a gente passa ali
pura diabo de pneu cai dentro eu não sei
quantas fotos eu tenho no meu instagram
1 milhão de buraco é rebate e furo diabo
do pneu mas hoje eu entendi que era para
evitar aglomerações você vê que que o
defeito não é administrativo não é
administrar você está tudo tranquilo
então assim com esse daqui a pouco
instante problema com essas informação
atravessada ainda havia o cara está
agoniado liga a televisão naquele jornal
de meio-dia quando você está em casa
você vai ouvir hoje sobre um pouco
o que é que tem gente que fala vírus
coronavírus pelo face que o menino tava
ela foi burrice só no vírus coronavírus
já tava já foi já falou não é igual aí
se eu te pego que você tem que dizer o
nome da música e já tá cantando a música
bota aquela ai se eu te pego não esquece
aquela ai se eu te pego ai se eu te pego
uma vírus foi levantado no brasil
auxiliadora one direction o vírus está
aterrorizando a família brasileira já já
a gente vai montar o caso do pequeno que
não precisa ele já tem 36 anos mas vai
precisar colo porque o menino de 7 anos
mas antes vamos lá do google complexo
vitamínico vida ver que não exemplo aí a
pessoa que já tá abestalhada sabe quanto
que tá acontecendo ela fica mais doida e
as pessoas despreza idozo viu como eu vi
gente que tu não tá nem aí para o senhor
de idade hoje eu descobri quem não gosta
de velho mas só pega e velha só velho
lave as mãos
o contato é vídeo tá saindo o papai quer
matar o velho agora morreu faz mal a
ninguém né rapaz vem só só anda
devagarzinho de carne espalhados é
porque o fato né quanto mais novo mais
interesse alto leite quanto mais velho
vai ficando ele vai cair naquele e lixar
físico né vamos cuidar dos idosos rapaz
os bichinho tem o pulmãozinho dele estão
todos coisa assim igual ele assim seus
ter medo vai todo descolando os cano
vazando as coisas para o lado para o
outro aí vem um cobra ponta bença vô e
passa o colono para o velho borra cara
higienizar suas mãos sabia evitar o
contato porque tem gente que realmente
não tem como ficar na quarentena 100% aí
se você não fica custa nada você lavar
sua mãozinha e evitar o contato para
senhora entendeu eu tenho vem indicar e
às vezes não cola mais ver um velho às
vezes tem geado parece que dormiu dentro
da garrafa receber os docinhos fofinho
pedir em mim né que são desse tamanho é
o pulmãozinho já tá indo devagarzinho
gilesio esquentando aqui o óleozinho
motorzinho passando por aqui teu tempo
aí você vai prejudicar
o velhinho do maranhão que a gente vai
com a senhorinhas no interior para o
capitão zinho da comida joga na boca dá
uma benção um menino deles que vêm em
são paulo como é que vai sempre a gente
chegar não vai ter uma senhorinha mais
vai eu pedi um copo d'água magrinha é
isso que vocês quer tens aí no maranhão
eu amo a velhinha do maranhão passa o
show no maranhão as velhinhas vão me
abraçar eu acho sensacional mas hoje eu
teria que evitar um abraço eu tivesse lá
no maranhão para poder proteger a
senhorita que eu já encontrei o senhor
se no maranhão que era tão velho
aniversário dele de super-heróis foi do
jaspion e não afeta só os idosos não meu
amigo afeta os idosos as pessoas que
problemas respiratórios as criancinhas
pequenininhas bem recém-nascidos não
podem encontrar essas coisas criança é
criança proteger a criança os
hipertensos os asmáticos que sabe que é
mais dos paranoicos eu sou paranoica tem
noção como é que a senhora sai da minha
cabeça não fico pensando meu deus é
aquelas corrente não tem controle né
gente não tem controle possível
asteroide do tamanho da terra rumo à
terra tudo bem a gente saber que ele tá
vindo e que a gente vai tentar
é isso não dá amigo eu começo já me
perturbar comigo mesmo que a gabriela
pugliesi diz que sente dor atrás dos
olhos a preta gil diz que é dor atrás
dos olhos eu digo dor atrás dos olhos é
ontem na cabeça tô com dor de cabeça e
infectado por aí conversa com meio mundo
de gente não não é assim não é vai
saindo né vai ficar normal tá pensa que
não eu tô aqui eu dou olha foi dormir
você gente perto de mim ó o terceiro tá
vindo e eu aqui para não tossir uma
tosse com acabei de inventar na minha
cabeça pensa que não já tô me sentindo
assim né imóveis normal é normal isso aí
você se sente assim mesmo tinha puxo
celular ai meu deus ave maria meu deus
deus me livre não passou um minuto até
esqueço tô normal quando passa um
pouquinho ator
tô me sentindo assim quente agora vou
deixar esse negócio lá minha cabeça da
10 minuto eu tô meu deus será que o cara
na itália ele chupou dele comendo show
não sei pode ser sintoma de gripe virose
normal ok tomar remédio fui lá pegar o
remédio botei na boca que ele tivesse
uma canoa que tem uns carro maria a
gente tem que ajeitar o caminho para ela
descer senão você morre engasgado aí ó ó
e aí senhora do google meu deus não pode
tomar remédio de gripe em caso de
sintomas de carona mas é o mesmo de novo
gol pode tomate menor meu deus abrir
começa a tomar conta da gente na visão e
as últimas notícias sobre o filhos bruna
e nos diz que não pode tomar tylenol in
tylenol pode mais o nosso vita vita 900
você pode comprar adquirir ligando para
o nosso amigo sérgio na mesmo você agiu
isso mesmo o sandro com precatório de
1889 900 é um dela não dou menos né não
tô pensando nada por tá com gripe a
pessoa vai que você tá com gripe e por
onde que não tem como te gripe corona
mesmo tem que ter ou não deixa as duas
doenças habitar no corpo de um ser ou
pode meu deus meu deus meu deus aí você
pergunta o médico tome água fica em casa
tome água tome água quero remédio pílula
botar na boca aqui ó no meu braço entra
vai entra entra entra sangue dentro
e fala logo eu quero sair eu não quero
isso em mim mas aí formei vocês aqui
primeiros testes das vacinas os humanos
já então vamos lá vamos sair sem pânico
vai dar tudo certo se a gente manter o
básico que é lavar as mãos com que
tiveram nossa é só ir para praia
mandando mensagem e vamos churrasco aqui
em casa cara já estão isolado aqui não
ficar isolado aqui chamar a galera ficar
isolado chamar a galera ficar isolado
maluco doido mas nós não vamos sair não
vamos ficar aqui aqui não tem velho tá
ligado não tem velho não tem velho meu
deus meu deus meu deus não tem velho meu
deus que não tem vem meu deus ai meu
deus mas depois tu volta para casa meus
pequenos claro e com jesus aí pega no
celular pura um pega criança bota no
colo aí passa a criança de colo em colo
que todo mundo gosta de criança
recém-nascida pequena que ainda não
enche o saco aí só aí fera todos nós
chega em casa da benção para vó
a cabeça ela fica aqui ó que é o glóbulo
dela no combate mais tão rápido já
travou eu tava fazendo show dos estados
unidos da nas áreas de risco tá meu deus
do céu tem que evitar o maior contato
possível e a pessoa que vieram e tá
vamos fazer o contato muito perto para
sei lá nunca se está toda aeroporto de
passar o gatinho chega aí no brasil cadê
o negócio de algum gel de conta que
pariu foi de lá para cá vou pegar aqui
que o brasileiro ele ele abusa deles e
café como é que tá as coisas tá bem
pensa que porque não tem bomba não tem
guerra não tem tsunami nada a ver que
vem para cá não pega eu acho que um
furacão ta chegando no brasil deus aluna
outra que falar que eu no brasil rapaz
foi brasil tão gente boa as pessoas tão
legal e olha aí um cachorro em caramelo
olha se não é incrível tem como ter
furacão ele tem um cachorro desse não
tem como como tá uma moto aqui para ir
correr atrás sabe meu filho para se
divertir o brasil do meio dos países é o
que gritei eu quando acontece alguma
coisa sabe tava vendo eu tinha os
estados unidos disse que vai mandar meio
mundo de tipo de bomba não sei para onde
o brasileiro ou região vai deixar ele
pega
e ai peppa contra essas coisas fica no
meu deus eu nunca tinha visto isso não
sabia disso jesus é a teus interessante
eu vi um vídeo esses dias de microscópio
é de cientista sabe quando tiver as
coisas pequenas muito grande uma
realidade tão grande que parece que
parece até os meus amigos seu sabe
nossas atitudes nossa eu tava vendo os
ovos atacando uma célula cancerígena
sabe parecia que era uma parada assim
coordenada mesmo parecia que era uma
parada assim tipo gente achei aqui o mal
vão destruir aí tinha toda aquela
coletividade que os glóbulos zinho
parece os cabeças de prego sabia que
eles iam tudo junto assim fazer a
verdade e destruindo as células
cancerígenas jeito a massa aquilo porque
me lembrou muito quando eu a dez
primeiras vezes de avião já haviam ele
subia enquanto mais distante ele é
ficando começar a prestar atenção que a
sociedade ela aparecia aquele vídeo
microscópio que eu tava vendo sabe você
de um prédio de 40 andares assim você
olha assim para baixo você olha para
baixo uma cerveja tipo um monte de
bonitinho não sabe seguindo seu rumo é o
caminho dentro daquela sociedade
o seu papel você viu o acidente de carro
dali você vê que são tuas coisinhas que
se choca e aí junto aquele mesmo tipo de
poesia vai junto um vira junta-se o que
quer que você falou que é isso aí tá é o
que facada foi que mataram ok ok é moto
é a maria não compra moto um perigo
depois ainda mais dois com um negocinho
vermelho girando aí aquele monte de
esperta né e sai que tava só
atrapalhando ali o negócio e o trânsito
aumentando aquele negócio grande só vai
ficando tudo parado entupido parece uma
vez no pisa sabe com o colesterol assim
um problema problema aí depois vem outro
cortando nem nem sai do meio de todo
mundo aí tem um negocinho que estava ali
tava aí leva quatro lugarzinho segue o
povo vai limpando parava de mandar coisa
que não tá normal do de novo tem
problema pequeno do acidente estava
incomodando última pessoa com 20 km de
engarrafamento e aquela pessoa nem sabe
o que que tá acontecendo aqui a
informação de um problema sinto mais com
que tudo seja muito maior do que é você
lá no final não sabe quanto tempo mais
você vai
o destino quanto tempo mais alguém vai
ter que esperar pelo que você tá levando
para essa pessoa quanto tempo mais vai
demorar você concluir aquele que você
queria concluir e aí vi essa coisa de
causa esse pânico esse medo a galera
comprando pois estocando aí outros vão
comprar não tem mais a precisa do leite
não tem mais porque alguém levou 20
leite para casa e nem criança tem por
isso eu queria pedir vocês aqui que se
informar se de verdade lembrando que eu
não acho que essa coisa que a gente tá
vivendo hoje todo acho que você para dar
um novo significado para você largar da
internet e para você viver a vida e viu
bom bonito e o pão o ser humano se
destrói porque eu não acho nada disso eu
acho isso uma grande bosta ninguém quer
que ter essa situação inteira não deixa
ninguém aprendendo nada nem fazendo nada
só é a incerteza e você fica triste com
tudo isso que tá acontecendo porque eu
mesmo queria tá fazendo meus eu mesmo
queria tá trabalhando mas como posso
ficar em quarentena eu vou ficar hoje
são os idosos né os mais afetados nada
que o bom dia quem é que sabe pode ficar
feio para nós a gente não tiver
o coletivo tá vendo até os animais
concordo então galera brincadeiras à
parte tal que a gente usar o coletivo e
ficar ligado nas questões básicas nas
coisas básicas a gente já se ajuda muito
porque tem gente que não consegue se dar
o luxo de parar entendeu é igual tubarão
separar o negócio desanda não tem como
mais fazendo as coisas básicas não é que
o negócio lá de fora para sua casa não
mas você também não passa a pessoa que
está prestando um serviço à você galera
por mais que as piadinhas estejam
presentes aí né na nossa nossa
brincadeira na nossa diversão que o que
a gente faz a gente faz do caroço uma
brincadeira ir para o brasileiro eu acho
que ela até um essência é muito difícil
retirar isso de nós sendo que ela cortou
genuíno sabe mas o coletivo ele pode ser
adicionado isso aí entendeu o ministério
mundial da preocupação falou cuide-se
então quando fala meu amigo o negócio é
sério que quando você tá no santarém tem
que acabar o papel higiênico eu sei que
você não vai parar de pagar entendeu
você quer papel higiênico e você quer
que alguém tinha colocado na prateleira
do supermercado para você e essa pessoa
tá em contato com as coisas que você tá
em contato não penso que tudo só chega
para você não
o ronaldinho e você tá passando com
outra pessoa então se preocupe com isso
se higienize e a coletividade vai dar
certo para nós é o cuidado básico que
vai proteger você quando você pedir
comida porque tem uma pessoa que faz a
comida e outro aqui embaixo tem outro
que entrega você só aqui que eu comprei
ela foi três mão que passou essas quatro
pessoas daqui fada aqui embala daqui
entrega e da que come se não houver a
coletividade os quatro talvez fique ruim
coletivo é importante que tá todo mundo
se uniu o mercado livre mesmo né o
centro do mercado livre era uma mão
segurando a outra assim fechando e gosta
deles mudar para ser dois cotovelos para
dizer assim não faz contato com a mão
qualquer coisa dá um totózinho cotovelo
ali entendeu tá todo mundo se une no as
coisas estão mudando the walking dead
agora tá mudando o nome também para ter
o álcool gel ou seja todos juntos que
você tá em quarentena no caso foi
dispensado do seu trabalho não sai de
férias e evite as aglomerações aqui em
casa se tiver alguém com sintomas é
vídeo compartilhar os objetos essas
pessoas um talher
ah entendeu a pega um pedaço de isso
aqui olha como tá gostoso come isso ai
meu deus tá fazendo aqui para esses atos
que a gente faz normalmente no dia a dia
que alimente-se bem também porque a
imunidade alta me ajuda a combater o
coronel também queria mandar um abraço a
todos os profissionais estão ajudando aí
a combater a enfermeiro é médico é
infectologista é tanta gente parabéns
aqui que a gente tem que falar o que é
que tem que falar e dá parabéns para
quem tem que ter parabéns vocês são
vocês demais meu amigo eu não sei o que
dizer que é só você e só vocês se você
repara para pensar no momento que está
vivendo hoje se não fosse vocês não sei
nem o que era nossa é isso aí eu espero
que você tenha gostado você tem se
divertir um pouquinho né nesse
quarentena aí seja de isolamento hoje é
o meu 5º dia de 40 e comenta aqui
embaixo como é que tá sendo a prevenção
na sua cidade tamo junto beijão espero
que você fique bem e sua família fique
bem que seus vezes querido as pessoas
que você ama fique bem que isso não
passe de um susto só que a gente está
vivendo tamo junto é nós um beijo de
mãos longe do rosto para não ter contato
com as voltas os narizes e os olhos